بعد قصه حب وزواج دام لمده 12 عاما اثمر
عن ثلاثه اطفال الفنان تامر حسني ينفصل
رسميا عن زوجته الفنانه المغربيه بسمه
بوسيل
[موسيقى]
اعتاد الجمهور دائما على خلافات الفنان
وزوجته والعديد من الشائعات التي تم
تداولها خلال السنوات الماضيه حول
انفصالهما وفورا انتشار الاخبار يعودان
مره اخرى ويظهر اني معا منها ما هو بسبب
المعجبات فقد فجرت بسمه بوسيل سابقا
مفاجاه عبر حسابها على انستجرام لكل الناس
الي بتبعث لي صور وفيديوهات لتامر وشايفه
انه مش بيعاملني باحترام سواء في الصور او
فيديوهات يا ريت تبطلوا تبعثوا لي اي حاجه
عشان مش فارقلي اي صور واضافته وكمان احب
اعرفكم ان احنا بقى لنا فتره منفصلين
وبنحضر اوراق الطلاق ورد عليها تامر حسني
حينها بحبك باسم متهوره
[موسيقى]
في حفظ الله